We have been hearing more and
more over the last several
weeks to a month and a half or so. Republicans
and right wing media pushing the narrative of
a crisis at the border and a surge in undocumented
crossings. Last week, we covered House Minority
Leader Republican Congressman Kevin McCarthy,
who staged an event at the US Mexico border,
said unaccompanied minors are coming to the U.S.
in crisis levels and the crisis was caused by Joe
Biden. Kevin McCarthy said that terrorists are
coming in through the US Mexico border border
from Yemen, Turkey and Yemen, Turkey and Iran.
It was there was no actual evidence of that.
But this is the narrative. It's been pushed
by Fox News reporters during press briefings
that's been pushed in news reports. It's been
pushed by Republicans at press conferences.
Is this real? Well, The Washington Post
analyzed Border Patrol data going back to 2012,
and there appears to be no crisis whatsoever.
There is no surge that we could link to Biden
administration policy. What we are seeing is data
that tracks a seasonal pattern. This is the time
of year where there are more migrants attempting
to cross and interacting with Border Patrol,
plus some what we might call pent up demand from
the covid period last year when movement was just
dramatically reduced. So if we look at a chart of
encounters per month at the border, looking at the
last few years and we're putting that up on the
screen, what you see is that numbers went up at
exactly this time of year in twenty nineteen. They
did not in twenty twenty because of the pandemic.
They went up slightly at this time in twenty
eighteen. And that's the pattern. It's a pattern
that's been observed for some time now. Yes.
Apprehended migrants are up twenty eight percent
from January to February, but apprehended migrants
were up 31 percent during the same period in
twenty nineteen. It is true that the raw numbers
are higher right now than last year and the year
before. Remember, movement in general went down
during the pandemic. So what you are seeing
number one right now is a resumption of movement.
And number two, some backed up demand from people
who did not move around last year. Now, let me
be very clear, because I know I'm going to get
emails about this. I'm not saying we don't need
total and complete immigration reform. We do.
This doesn't mean that Joe Biden has done
enough to stop deportations. He hasn't,
and I've talked about that. It simply is not the
crisis that Republicans want you to think it is.
It's the crisis that we've had in this country for
a long time, combined with a lack of comprehensive
immigration reform, which I and others have been
calling for for just as long of a time. What Trump
did last year with Title 42, which is using
the pandemic as a reason to turn people around
and deport, it seems to have delayed people
from coming, not stopped people from coming,
period. That's the story. Many of them are
coming now, not because Joe Biden is president,
but because the pandemic is to some degree easing,
almost identical to Joe Biden's surge in gas
prices last week, which we covered earlier this
week. We are seeing gas prices go up. It's not
because of Joe Biden. They started going up in
October when Donald Trump was still president.
And what we're seeing is demand for gasoline
recover as the pandemic starts to ease. It has
nothing to do with Joe Biden. So serious media
should really just report this based on facts,
but without using the language that the right
uses. You know, when you talk about border crisis,
it's sort of like sleepy Joe in China virus. These
are terms that the right uses to frame the debate
in a particular way where you're no longer
questioning whether there is a border crisis,
you're merely arguing as to whose fault it is
and to what degree it exists. And this is how
the right does really well at framing issues. It
keeps Republican voters enraged. It doesn't really
allow solutions to the problems, however. So
call it a predictable seasonal pattern that we've
observed for a decade, bolstered by the waning of
coronavirus to some degree and even none like what
we even what we would call non right wing media
is using a lot of the terms of the right when they
talk about this. And as I've talked about before,
using their don't let them even set the agenda and
narrative by using the language. And that's what
they successfully have done on so many issues
for decades, as we've talked about with people
like George Lakoff and Thomas Frank here on the
program. So don't fall for it. Here's the data.
The data is clear and we're going to continue to
track that data tomorrow, Friday, finally, the day
is here, the one day David Pakman show membership
special. We are doing a massive blowout of
memberships. We're hoping for massive membership
dumps tomorrow. If you want to be notified of a
one day, I hesitate to even say that it's a moral
discount. I believe the discount we're offering
tomorrow is immoral. It's vaccine themed. If you
want to be notified tomorrow morning, just
get on my newsletter at David Pakman Dotcom.